I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, hello. Hi.
我是詹娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。哈喽，哈喽。嗨。
Guess what we're talking about today. It's yourself, woof.com. Oh my gosh. Ryan's startup company is here. This is season seven, episode nine. It was written by Aaron Scherr and directed by Danny Liener. He was a new director for us. He had directed Dude Where's My Car and Harold and Kumar Go To White Castle.
猜猜我们今天要聊什么。就是 woof.com。天哪。瑞安的创业公司来啦。这是第七季第九集。由埃伦·谢尔编剧，丹尼·利纳尔执导。他是我们的新导演。他曾执导过《我的车在哪儿》和《寻堡奇遇》。
We had a lot of fun. We did. Here is your summary, Ryan and Michael's business venture woof.com has hit a snag. And their investors slash co-workers are pressuring them to sell the company. Sell the company? The company is days old. No. It's hit a snag so quickly.
我们玩得很开心。确实如此。以下是本集剧情梗概：瑞安和迈克尔的商业合资公司 woof.com 遇到了麻烦。他们的投资者兼同事正向他们施压，要求他们卖掉公司。卖掉公司？这家公司才成立几天啊。不。麻烦来得太快了。
There's a lot of graphs for it, though. So many color copies. Oh, I love that runner. I don't like to be a lousy snitch. Well, in the meantime, there's a new corporate policy, Ye Olde Commission Cap, and Jim has hit his commission cap so he no longer feels motivated to work. And finally, Dwight is going to relive his childhood by turning the parking lot into a hay festival, which leads Angela into the arms of a new man.
不过，这上面有很多图表。彩色复印件真多。哦我喜欢这个副线剧情。我不喜欢当个卑鄙的告密者。好吧，与此同时，公司出台了一项新政策——也就是古老的佣金上限，吉姆的佣金已经达到了上限，所以他再也没有工作的动力了。最后，德怀特要重温童年，把停车场变成一个干草节，这让安吉拉投入了一个新男人的怀抱。
Oh, yeah. You know what? This was our Thanksgiving episode, I realized. That's why there's a hay festival. This aired on November 18, 2010. We're always asking, where's our Thanksgiving episode? I think this was it. Here you go, woof.com.
哦，是的。你知道吗？我意识到，这是我们的感恩节特辑。这就是为什么会有干草节。这集于2010年11月18日播出。我们总是问，我们的感恩节特辑在哪里？我想就是这集了。给你，woof.com。
Well, we're really excited because today, we are going to talk to our writer of this episode and friend, Aaron Scherr. Yes. Aaron was so lovely, and we got to talk to him for quite a bit. He was such a great guest. Jenna, you and I always love it when writers get to come on. Well, we're such nerds for the writing process, I think. We are.
好吧，我们非常兴奋，因为今天我们要和本集的编剧、我们的朋友埃伦·谢尔聊聊。是的。埃伦人太好了，我们和他聊了挺久。他是一位非常棒的嘉宾。詹娜，你和我总是很喜欢编剧们来做客。嗯，我想我们对写作过程都是十足的狂热爱好者。确实是的。
Well, here's our conversation with Aaron. Hello, Aaron! Hi! Woohoo! Everyone, we're so excited we're being joined by our writer, Aaron Scherr, who, by the way, was nominated for a Writer's Guild Award for episodic comedy for this episode, woof.com. That was one of the high points of my career was getting that nomination. Well, we loved this episode, woof!
好吧，这是我们与埃伦的对话。你好，埃伦！嗨！呜呼！各位，我们非常高兴能邀请到我们的编剧埃伦·谢尔，顺便说一下，他因本集 woof.com 获得了美国编剧工会奖 episodic 喜剧类提名。获得那个提名是我职业生涯的高光时刻之一。好吧，我们太喜欢这集了，woof！
I was cracking up. I hadn't seen this episode in so long. I know we always say that because we are doing a rewatch in real time, but I was cracking up. Yeah. We really enjoyed the chance to revisit it, and the number of person hours that went into it, crazy, 25 pages of notes from Jonathan Hughes and Kelly Hanne and the Writing Assistance. Wow.
我当时笑得前仰后合。我好久没看这集了。我知道我们总是这么说，因为我们在实时重温，但我真的笑喷了。是的。我们真的很享受重新回顾它的机会，为此投入的人时真是疯狂，乔纳森·休斯、凯利·汉妮和编剧助理们写了25页的笔记。哇。
Wow. And then we whittled that down to a beat sheet and then to an outline and then an initial draft and then a lot changed after the table draft. The game character is Zach Woods. Normally when you're a writer, people will be like, how much do the actors make up? Actors usually bring so much more to it than just coming up with lines, right? But it's almost never as much improv as people think. You're like, usually it's more or less what we wrote and they come up with, they will
哇。然后我们把它精简成节拍表，再到大纲，接着是初稿，然后在围读剧本后又做了很多改动。那个游戏角色是扎克·伍兹。通常当你是一名演员时，人们会问，演员们即兴发挥了多少？演员们带来的东西通常远不止想出几句台词，对吧？但几乎从来没有像人们想象的那么多即兴发挥。你会想，通常这或多或少就是我们写的，然后他们会想出，他们会
add things, especially brilliant improvisers like Steve Carell are going to bring new stuff. But generally speaking, we do the writing and they do the acting. But Zach kind of improvised that whole thing about being in the men's room and looking away. Yes. I remember that. And John couldn't keep a straight face. I remember that scene where John is complaining about the commission cap and then Gabe gives
加入一些东西，特别是像史蒂夫·卡瑞尔这样才华横溢的即兴表演者，会带来新的东西。但总的来说，我们负责写，他们负责演。不过扎克算是即兴发挥了整段关于在男厕所里并把视线移开的内容。是的。我记得那个。约翰都快笑场了。我记得那个场景，约翰在抱怨佣金上限，然后盖布给
us a long analogy about how well sometimes there are regulations you don't agree with. Like men are allowed to walk around naked at my gym and I don't like it, but it's, you know, that's their policy. I looked in the script because I was like, that sounds like Zach. He would go on these just bizarre tangents. He's a brilliant improviser. Yes. And that, that was an amazing speech.
了我们一个长长的类比，大意是，有时候有些规定你就是不同意。就像在我健身房里允许男人光着身子走来走去，我虽然不喜欢，但你知道的，这就是他们的规矩。我在剧本里查过，因为我想，这听起来太像扎克了。他总是会陷入这种极其离奇的题外话中。他是个才华横溢的即兴表演者。是的。而且那段演讲太精彩了。
Well, let's take you a little bit back to the beginning. How long did you work as a writer on the office? Well I was there five, four seasons, wait, five, six, seven, eight, so four seasons. The season when the, the Scranton Strangler was around too, that's just coincidental. I wasn't, I wasn't. Well before you worked on the office, you worked on Everybody Loves Raymond and the New Adventures of Old Christine, those were both three camera shows in front of a live audience.
好吧，让我们带你稍微回到最初。你在《办公室》当了多久的编剧？我在那儿呆了五季，四季，等等，五、六、七、八，所以是四季。斯克兰顿扼杀者出没的那一季也在里面，那纯属巧合。我不在，我不在。好吧，在你加入《办公室》之前，你曾在《人人都爱雷蒙德》和《老妈qupd》工作过，这两部都是在现场观众面前拍摄的三机位情景喜剧。
I'm curious, what was the difference between working on shows like that versus working on the office? Which was single camera. Yeah. Well, the writing part is fairly similar. The biggest difference is in the production. So when you're comparing single camera to multi-cam, it was my first single camera show. And one of the things is, you know, a multi-cam is shot like a stage production, like you're
我很好奇，像那种节目和《办公室》这样的节目有什么区别？后者是单机位拍摄的。是的。嗯，写作部分其实挺相似的。最大的区别在于制作上。所以当你把单机位和多机位进行对比时，这是我的第一部单机位剧集。其中一点是，你知道的，多机位是像舞台制作那样拍摄的，就像你在
watching a play. And usually, ideally there's a real audience there enjoying it and you can't get that energy. Whereas our show, the office was, you know, shot like a movie and the camera is a character. And so you're in the space and it's much tighter and like people are speaking more quietly and more realistically. But for me being on the set, I was used to laughing loudly to try to encourage the actors and make it clear what parts were the joke. And so I had to learn not to do that.
看一出戏剧。而且通常，理想情况下现场会有真正的观众在欣赏，你无法复制那种能量。而我们的节目，《办公室》你知道的，是像电影一样拍摄的，摄像机本身就是一个角色。所以你置身于那个空间里，场景紧凑得多，人们说话也更轻声、更逼真。但对我来说，在片场时，我习惯了大声笑出来以鼓励演员，并让人听清楚哪些部分是笑话。所以我不得不学会克制自己不要那样做。
I remember my first episode was Baby Shower and Greg Daniels was directing and he had to keep telling me like, hey, don't laugh, be quiet. And so I'd go home and have held in some, because oh my God, the performances were so amazing and so funny and it's so hard not to laugh. So I'd go home and feel all this pent up laughter and it'd usually come out and like, you know, indigestion and burps and stuff. But also there was sort of a generational change from Raymond to The Office, then other shows I've gone on to like People of Earth in terms of how we relate to the internet,
我记得我的第一集是《送婴派对》，格雷格·丹尼尔斯担任导演，他不得不一直提醒我：嘿，别笑，保持安静。所以我回家后就会憋着，因为天啊，他们的表演太精彩了，太搞笑了，不笑简直太难了。所以我回家后会感到满肚子的笑意无处宣泄，通常它们会化为消化不良和打嗝什么的。但除此之外，《雷蒙德》到《办公室》，再到我后来参与的其他节目（比如《地球人》），我们在如何与互联网互动方面经历了一种代际变化，
which is apropos of this episode, right, which on every bill as Raymond, we would be like, don't go to those chat boards, don't, you know, my space. And then on The Office, we were, you know, interacting with Office Tally and Jenny Tan and we were kind of doing the equivalent of live streaming in that day during an episode when the episode would air, we would, the writing staff would get on and be like tweeting. So on The Office, we would draw from the internet. It was, it was like a reciprocal relationship where we would talk to the internet and the internet would talk to us and we would take so from the internet like in, you know, wedding
这与这一集很契合，对吧？在《雷蒙德》的每一集制作中，我们都会说，别去看那些聊天论坛，别去，你知道的，MySpace。而在《办公室》里，你知道的，我们与 Office Tally 和珍妮·坦进行互动，我们在当时的那种日子里做着相当于直播的事情——当一集播出时，编剧团队会登录并开始发推特。所以在《办公室》里，我们会从互联网中汲取灵感。这就像是一种双向关系，我们和互联网对话，互联网也和我们对话，我们会从互联网上取材，比如婚礼
dance was straight off the internet and YouTube, right. And also lip dubs, like the opening of nepotism where there was a lip dub and you see Woof.com in there. Well, you know, on our show, a lot of times you guys would pitch us lines in the moment because we've said this before, the writers were on set with us. But my small experience with multicam is that you sort of figure out your jokes and change your jokes in the rehearsal process. And there's not a lot of like on the shoot day coming up with new jokes.
舞蹈就是直接取自互联网和YouTube，对吧？还有对口型表演，比如《任人唯亲》的开场，里面有一个对口型表演，你能在里面看到 Woof.com。嗯，你知道的，在我们的节目里，很多时候你们会当场给我们抛出台词，因为我们以前说过，编剧们是和我们一起在片场的。但我对多机位微薄的经验是，你们在排练过程中基本上就把笑话定下来并加以修改了。而在拍摄当天，大家并不会现场想出很多新笑话。
Is that true or did you feel pressure while we were shooting that you had to stand there and throw new lines at us? Yes. Well, we would have, you know, a candy bag with lots of alternative lines ready to go. We would write a lot of pages that would not end up in the final cut. They maybe would be deleted scenes, but on a on a multicam, like everybody lives Raymond, we pretty much had every page that we wrote would end up in the final episode, whereas on the office, we would lose 20, 30 percent of pages.
这是真的吗？还是说我们在拍摄时，你会感到压力，觉得自己必须站在那里给我们抛出新台词？是的。嗯，我们当时会准备一个“糖果袋”，里面装满了随时可用的备选台词。我们会写很多最终不会出现在剪辑版里的页数。它们可能会成为删减片段，但在多机位节目里，比如《人人都爱雷蒙德》，我们写几乎每一页都会出现在最终播出的剧集里，而在《办公室》里，我们会舍弃百分之二十到三十的页数。
Oh, yeah. And that's the power of the doc style, though, because it's it's found footage. It's okay if it feels like, you know, you're not seeing every single moment and you can lose a lot and still have the story be there. And you can only you're able to keep just the best moments. I remember once I was went to a panel to just for of aspiring writers. And I showed an episode I wrote, it might have been Wolf, and it was on a DVD. Remember DVDs?
哦，是的。不过这就是纪录片风格的力量所在，因为它是找到的素材。即使感觉你没有看到每一个瞬间，也可以没问题，你依然可以舍弃很多内容，同时故事依然成立。而且你能够只保留最精彩的时刻。我记得有一次我去参加一个专门针对有志编剧的小组讨论会。我播放了我写的一集，可能就是《Woof》，它是刻在DVD上的。还记得DVD吗？
And I accidentally hit play of deleted scenes and I didn't realize it. And so we were watching only the deleted scenes and it had the basic shape of the entire episode. And I thought, wow, this is oddly edited for syndication, but it was so like there was enough of a like upside down world version of the episode there that we had written and shot that didn't make it, you know. So sometimes you would have to write scenes with enough story markers in it so that if it's the only part of this story that survives, there's enough there to hold it up as a story.
我一不小心按下了播放删减片段，自己却没有意识到。所以我们当时只在看删减片段，而它竟然有着整集的基本框架。我想，天啊，这剪辑为了辛迪加播放也太诡异了吧，但它里面确实有足够多的我们写过并拍摄过却没能播出的、属于那一集的“颠倒世界”版内容，你知道的。所以有时候你必须在场景中写入足够的剧情标记，这样即使这是这个故事唯一存活的部分，也足以支撑它作为一个完整的故事。
So there was a big flexibility in the editing, probably more so than a multicam. Okay, I have a question for you, Erin. We have shared with our podcast listeners that you were the quote, king of cold opens. You really were. You came up with some of the most brilliant ones. I mean, everyone knows Kevin's chili. That is like the spill heard around the world, but were there some other ones that you wrote that you would like to share with us?
所以在剪辑方面有很大的灵活性，可能比多机位节目还要大。好的，埃伦，我有个问题想问你。我们曾和播客听众分享过，你是所谓的“开场白之王”。你真的是实至名归。你想出了一些最绝妙的开场。我的意思是，每个人都知道凯文的辣椒。那简直是轰动全球的“泼洒事件”，但你还写过其他什么你想和我们分享的开场吗？
Or do you have a favorite? So yeah, I came up, especially even season five, there was a fair number of cold opens that I kind of came up with the PA system, I believe was my idea. And actually that was from the offices of everybody loves Raymond. We figured out that you could do that, that there was a code you could hit on any phone and you'd suddenly have the entire PA system at your disposal. So that was from basically I didn't come up with things, I just remembered things. Cheese puffs was another thing I came up with.
或者你有没有最喜欢的一个？嗯，我确实想出了不少，特别是第五季的时候，有不少开场白都是我想出来的，我想内部广播系统就是我的主意。实际上那是从《人人都爱雷蒙德》的办公室里获得的灵感。我们发现你可以做到这一点，只要在任何电话上按一个密码，你就能瞬间掌控整个内部广播系统。所以那基本上不是我想出来的，我只是记住了别人的东西。芝士球是我想出来的另一个点子。
Whether or not I was in the kitchen and I saw the cheese puffs and I threw one into my mouth. And that's, you know, when you're a writer, that's what you do. You're like, is this a thing? Is this, you know, I'm tapping my, I'm tapping my pencil. Is that a thing? You know, you're just constantly trying to desperate to come up with ideas. Gosh, all of these are really so memorable to you said cheese puff cold open.
无论我当时是否在厨房，我看到了芝士球，然后扔了一个进嘴里。这就是，你知道的，当你是个编剧时，你就会这么做。你会想，这算个事儿吗？这，你知道的，我在敲我的，我在敲我的铅笔。这算个事儿吗？你知道的，你只是不断地、拼命地想要想出点子。天哪，所有这些都真的让人印象深刻，你刚才说的是芝士球开场。
I mean, that I get that sent to me all the time. People want to know if we really caught them and all that. You know, that was an example though where people throwing cheese puffs into their own mouths is not in and of itself a great idea, but what you did with it made it so delightful. And you were really, I mean, I just watched, I rewatched that and it's so what you did made it a thing, you know, the way you reacted to it. And it's also kind of impressive that you, you were able to do that. But I feel like that little thing, it's, it's really cool because it's so relatable.
我的意思是，那个片段总是有人发给我。人们想知道我们是不是真的接住了它们之类的。你知道，那是一个例子，人们把芝士球扔进自己嘴里本身并不是一个绝妙的主意，但你对它所做的处理让它变得如此妙趣横生。而且你真的，我的意思是，我刚刚看了，我重温了那一集，你所做的事情让它成了一个梗，你知道的，你对它的反应方式。而且你能做到这一点也挺让人印象深刻的。但我觉得那个小细节，它真的很酷，因为它是如此地引起共鸣。
We've all done that with popcorn or whatever. Maybe you're procrastinating or, you know, it's such a relatable thing. And then the other thing that's so relatable is like coming up with bigger stunts for yourself, you know, trick shots with food and, and then the joy when you land one that you came up with, that's just, that's a thing. Yeah. Like you tapped into something. I think you're so great, Erin, at just observing and then bringing what you've observed to
我们都用爆米花或什么东西做过那种事。也许你在拖延，或者，你知道的，这是一个极具共鸣的事情。然后另一件同样能引起共鸣的事情就是，为自己设计更大胆的特技动作，你知道的，用食物玩花式投篮，然后当你成功投进一个自己想出来的球时，那种喜悦感，这就是一回事。是的。就像你触碰到了某种共鸣。埃伦，我觉得你太厉害了，善于观察，然后把你观察到的东西搬上
the page and I would love to see your notes because I feel like, are you someone when you go out in the world or you travel, are you like jotting down little moments? Yes. Yes. A lot of three by five cards, actually. Oh, you're speaking Angela's language. Well, you, I know you go, you've talked about that, how much, how much we tried to externalize the stories by putting them on three by five cards and putting, attacking them to the wall.
稿纸。我很想看看你的笔记，因为我觉得，当你出门在外或旅行时，你会不会把这些小片刻随时记下来？是的。是的。实际上用了大量三乘五英寸的卡片。哦，你说到安吉拉的心坎里去了。嗯，你，我知道你会去，你曾经谈到过这一点，我们多么努力地把故事外化——把它们写在三乘五英寸的卡片上，然后把它们钉在墙上。
And, you know, as you show in your book, there's all those, you know, the writer's room is just festooned with them and it's a great, you know, Greg Daniels, that was always his, one of his many great writing ideas is trying to externalize it, get it out of your head, put it down on paper and, and it makes, makes it something you can literally manipulate in the world. And it also gives you a new perspective on the, on the idea. So it's. Was there ever a note card you put on the wall that, that didn't make it, but you still
而且，正如你在书中所展示的，到处都是那些，你知道的，编剧室里到处挂满了卡片，这是一个很棒的，你知道的，格雷格·丹尼尔斯，那一直是他的伟大编剧理念之一，就是试着将它外化，把它从你的脑子里拿出来，写在纸上，这就使它变成了你可以在现实世界中亲手操控的东西。它也为你提供了一个审视这个点子的新视角。所以。有没有哪张你贴在墙上的便签卡，最后没被采纳，但你依然
remember it? Tons of them. I kept, one of them is the, I wanted there to be a, if not a cold open an entire episode where Michael actually gets rose colored glasses, because he's heard that expression and he wonders, you know, what it's like. So he literally gets rose colored glasses and then drives to work. And it's true life is much better when you have rose colored glasses, because all the lights were green.
记得它？成吨的卡片。我留着一张，其中一个是，我希望有一个——如果不是开场白的话，甚至可以是一整集——迈克尔真的去买了一副有色眼镜，因为他听过那个表达，他很想知道（戴着它）是什么感觉。所以他真的买了一副玫瑰色的眼镜，然后开车去上班。结果证明生活确实好多了，因为有了玫瑰色眼镜，所有的红绿灯都是绿的。
There wasn't a single red light on the way to work and people were waving at them like your life is better when you. That actually sounds like an amazing cold open. Like I can just see Michael. Yeah. That's the thing. I fully see him doing it. Like buying them and be like, everyone's my friend, everything's awesome.
上班路上居然连一个红灯都没有，人们还向他挥手，就好像你的生活变好了，当你。这听起来其实是个绝妙的开场白。我脑海里立刻就能浮现出迈克尔的样子。是的。就是这样。我完全能想象他这么做。就像买下它们然后说：大家都是我的朋友，一切都太棒了。
He's causing accidents left and right. And I found a card that just said, all it said is twice tarantula gets loose. Oh. Uh-huh. So I don't know where that goes. Probably ends up on Creed somehow. Of course. No, it goes in Creed's, Creed's drawer of mug beans.
结果他引发了一起又一起的车祸。我还找到了一张卡片，上面只写着一句话：克里德的狼蛛跑出来了。哦。呃——huh。所以我不知道这个情节该放在哪。可能最后莫名其妙安到克里德身上了。当然。不，这应该放进克里德的怪豆抽屉里。
We wanted to ask you a little bit about the talks that went into season seven and knowing that this was going to be Steve Carell's last year, which meant that it was Michael Scott's last year. What was that discussion like in the writer's room? How to handle his exit? It wasn't like one discussion. It was just a constant discussion. We were obsessed with this question.
我们想和你聊聊关于第七季筹备时的种种讨论，当时我们知道这将是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的最后一年，这意味着这也是迈克尔·斯科特的最后一年。编剧室里当时是怎么讨论的？该如何处理他的退场？这可不是简简单单的一次讨论。这是一场持续不断的讨论。我们对这个问题简直着迷了。
It was scary. And so you got 15 writers. We pretty much had every conversation you could have about how are we going to do this. And we even went as far as to write like a talking point memo of things that actors and producers could say to the press about it. I do remember getting an email from, I think it was Greg that said, here you guys, if you're asked about Steve leaving or Michael leaving or what's going to happen to the show, here's things you can say.
这太让人焦虑了。于是你有15个编剧。关于我们要怎么做这件事，能进行的讨论我们基本上都做过。我们甚至还写了一份谈话要点备忘录，列出了演员和制片人可以就此事向媒体发表的言论。我的确记得收到过一封邮件，我想要么是格雷格发来的，上面写着：伙计们，如果你们被问到关于史蒂夫离开、迈克尔离开，或者节目会发生什么，这里有一些你们可以回答的话。
Yes. Which was very helpful. Yeah. Because we were asked a lot. And I think one of the smartest things that I don't know if it was Greg or Paul who came up with the idea, which is that he left before the end of the season, which was just so smart because it gives, yes, he's leaving, but it's not a finale. That's still the office and the office goes on and here's an example of three episodes
是的。这真的非常有帮助。对，因为我们经常被问到。而且我认为最聪明的举措之一——我不知道这是格雷格还是保罗想出的主意——那就是他在季末之前就离开了。这真的太聪明了，因为它表明：是的，他要离开，但这并不是大结局。这依然是《办公室》，《办公室》还将继续，这里有三集的内容作为我们向你们承诺的范例。
of what we are promising you. And there's the fun of who is it going to be, who's going to actually come in and replace him. It was scary. It was scary. But I think Steve was very clear that he didn't see himself as the show and he was very generous in letting it continue in a way that showed that as important as Michael was to the show, the ensemble was also very important.
而且还有那种悬念的乐趣：究竟会是谁？谁会真正来接替他的位置？当时真的很吓人。真的很吓人。但我认为史蒂夫非常清醒，他不认为自己就是整部剧的化身，而且他非常大度地让这部剧得以延续，这种方式表明，尽管迈克尔对这部剧至关重要，但全体演员阵容同样极其重要。
Yeah. Coming back to wolf.com for a second, we were curious who came up with the idea of the Hay King, the Hay Place, Hay Festival, Dwight's whole Hay existence. This is an interesting journey for me because when you've been on writing staffs for a while, you learn to go with the flow, right? You read the room and if you're a professional writer, you know, you roll in the direction that the room's going, but I actually didn't like Hay Place at first. It wasn't my idea and I didn't love it and I don't know why I had such a burr in my saddle
嗯，我们把话题稍微拉回 woof.com。我们很好奇，是谁想出了干草之王、干草小镇、干草节、德怀特关于干草的一切这个主意？对我和说这段经历挺有趣的，当你加入编剧团队一段时间后，你就会学会随波逐流，对吧？你会察言观色，如果你是个职业编剧，你知道的，你会顺着房间里正在形成的思路走，但我其实一开始并不喜欢“干草小镇”这个点子。这不是我的主意，而且我当时并不怎么喜欢它，我也不知道为什么自己对它那么排斥。
about it. I think I imagined, I mean, this is sort of an obvious thing, but it's good to remember that you don't know what's going to happen. You don't know when you have just an idea, it could be the best thing ever or the worst thing ever. All depends on execution. And I just sort of had a bad version of it in my head and I sort of felt like, well, how much resources does Dwight have to build a Hay maze?
我想我当时想象的是——我的意思是，这其实是个显而易见的道理，但记住这一点很好：你永远不知道接下来会发生什么。当只有一个创意时，你根本不知道它最终会变成史上最棒的点子还是最烂的点子。这一切全取决于执行情况。而我当时在脑海里对它有一个不好的版本，我甚至觉得，德怀特究竟有多少资源去建造一个干草迷宫？
Does he really have the ability to do it? And so I kind of had a bad attitude about it. Yeah, the maze was big, but I saw them build it and it's doable. It's doable that two people could have built that maze in a weekend. And so the other thing, though, we got a little feedback from the internet was that's not Hay, it's straw. Oh my gosh, Erin, when we are finished speaking with you today and we're breaking down this episode, you would not believe the mail that we got about this from farmers across the
他真的有能力做到这一点吗？所以我对它抱有一种不太好的态度。是的，那个迷宫确实挺大，但我亲眼看他们搭建了它，而且这是可行的。两个人花一个周末把那个迷宫建起来是完全做得到的。不过还有一件事，我们从互联网上收到了一些反馈，那就是：那根本不是干草（Hay），那是麦秸（Straw）。哦天哪，埃伦，当我们今天和你聊完并复盘这一集时，你绝对不会相信我们收到了来自全国各地农场主的来信，
country, that that is straw, it is not Hay and I've got a whole deep dive about it. Jenna said there was a fan mail flurry from a lot of agricultural folks who really wanted you to know. Oh yeah. I learned something. I learned a lot about Hay and straw. Hay is, do you know, I don't want to steal your thunder, but you know, Hay is dangerous. You know, it can combust spontaneously.
他们指出那是麦秸，根本不是干草，为此我还做了一整番深入研究。詹娜说有一大波粉丝来信，来自许多农业界人士，他们非常想让你知道这一点。哦，是的。我学到了一课。我了解了很多关于干草和麦秸的知识。你知道干草是，你知道的——我不想抢你的风头，但你知道干草是很危险的吗？你知道它会自然起火吗？
What? If you pack your Hay too tightly and it gets wet, it will become a huge fire. I did not know this and this is not part of my breakdown. I did not know this either and my dad grew Hay and I'm going to talk about that as well when we get to it. Yeah, and you have to monitor the, you have to stick things into your Hay bail to make sure it's not going to combust, to make, to monitor it. That I do remember.
什么？如果你把干草压得太紧而且它受潮了，它就会变成一颗巨大的定时炸弹。我以前根本不知道这一点，这也不在我的复盘笔记里。我以前也不知道这一点，我爸爸以前种干草，等我们聊到那部分时，我也会谈到这个。是的，你必须监测，你必须把测量工具插进干草包里，以确保它不会自燃，以此来进行监测。那个我倒是记得。
I remember my dad doing that, but I didn't understand why. Erin, are these all things that you learned about Hay and straw after the episode aired? During, well, during the process, I was researching it and the part I didn't know going into it was that they would use straw. I thought there would be Hay, but then it turns out for obvious reasons you would use actual straw. Straw is just structurally better. But I think one of the best reasons for that Hay place to exist was the scene between the
我记得我爸爸以前那么做过，但我当时不明白是为什么。埃伦，这些都是你在这一集播出后才学到的关于干草和麦秸的知识吗？在过程中——嗯，在制作过程中，我做过调研。我一开始不知道的一点是他们会使用麦秸。我以为会用干草，但后来证明，出于显而易见的原因，你必须使用真正的麦秸。麦秸在结构上要结实得多。不过我认为“干草小镇”存在的最佳理由之一，就是参议员和安吉拉之间的那场戏，尤其是重新观看时，那成了我最喜欢的场景之一。
senator and Angela, which was one of my favorite scenes, rewatching it especially. And that was not in my original draft. The fact that he laughs at you and thinks, well, he thinks Angela is funny. And for her, that's a new experience and I was just such a, like that got me. That moment got me also the moment when Michael says he knows who Ryan is, but he's still going to have faith in him the way he did and the rest of the staff that rewatching it. I was like, wow, that's amazing.
而且那并不在我的初稿里。事实上，他竟然对你笑，并且觉得——嗯，他觉得安吉拉很有趣。对她来说，这是一次全新的体验，而我真的被触动了。那一刻触动了我，还有迈克尔说他知道瑞安是谁，但他依然要像以前和对待其他员工那样信任他——再次观看时，我心想：哇，这太棒了。
That just really, I kind of teared up a little bit because I think that's the quintessential Michael Scott moment where he's got a wrong idea, but for all the right reasons. Yeah. Erin, so much of your real life has made its way into episodes of The Office. Was there anything from this episode that was inspired by your real life? Apart from having made a lot of bad investments, I have felt that like, oh my gosh, is this a bad investment? Yes, usually it was.
这真的，让我有点感动，因为我认为这是最典型的迈克尔·斯科特时刻：他抱着一个错误的想法，但出发点却完全是出于好的理由。埃伦，你的很多现实生活都被写进了《办公室》的剧集中。这一集里有没有什么情节是从你的现实生活获得灵感的？除了做过很多糟糕的投资之外，我都曾有过这种感觉，天啊，这难道是一次糟糕的投资吗？是的，通常确实如此。
But other than that, it's, you know, let me see. Just bad investment anxiety, you were able to write to that very authentically. Yeah. Well, Erin, thank you so much for coming and talking with us. I always love hearing a writer's perspective. You guys are always my favorite people to hang out with on a project. And on the show too, we were always popping in the writer's room, probably driving you guys crazy.
但除此之外，你知道的，让我想想。仅仅是对投资失败的焦虑，你就能够非常真实地把它写出来。是的。好吧，埃伦，非常感谢你来和我们聊聊。我总是很喜欢听取编剧的视角。在项目中，你们一直是我最喜欢一起泡在一起的人。在片场也是，我们总是时不时闯进编剧室，可能把你们烦透了吧。
Was it annoying or did you like us? We loved it. We would love it when you would come in. Okay. Was it just because we gave you a break or because you actually liked us and our ideas? One of the things we would do is watch what you did and how you talked, and it was almost inevitable that it would influence what we thought about your character. So we were paying attention.
你们当时觉得很烦，还是其实挺喜欢我们的？我们超爱。每当你们走进来，我们都会开心得不得了。好吧，那是因为我们能让你们休息一下，还是因为你们真的喜欢我们和我们的点子？我们经常做的一件事就是观察你们的一举一动和说话方式，这几乎不可避免地会影响我们对你们角色的看法。所以我们一直在关注着呢。
Oh, that is terrifying. And Erin, lastly, is there any project that you're working on that we can share about? Well, I recently wrote a script with Norman Lear, who just turned 100. Wow. It was for Nathology. So I'd never done that before where it's just a one-off creating an entire world and a bunch of characters for one episode. It was with Shondaland for Netflix, but the series didn't go, but our episode was so well
哦，这太可怕了。埃伦，最后，有什么你正在参与的项目我们可以和大家分享的吗？嗯，我最近和刚刚满100岁的诺曼·莱尔合作写了一个剧本。哇。那是为《Nathology》写的。我以前从来没做过这种事，那就是创作一个仅此一次的独立世界，并为单集创造一整群角色。那是为网飞（Netflix）旗下的Shondaland制作的，不过这个系列剧最终没有被预订，但我们的单集反响太好了，
received that we're trying to find a way to make it its own series. So we're doing that. That's fantastic. Yeah. Amazing. Well, Erin, thank you so much for stopping by Office Ladies. Do you know we're going to keep bugging you because we're going to keep wanting your input about episodes?
以至于我们正试图找机会把它做成一个独立的剧集。所以我们正在为此努力。太棒了。是的。太惊艳了。好吧，埃伦，非常感谢你来到“办公室女士”播客做客。你知道的，我们以后还会继续纠缠你的，因为我们总是想要你对剧集的意见！
We love your stories. Please do. I love listening to your show and I love reliving even the parts that I wasn't there for. And congratulations on such an amazing podcast and your book, too. Thank you. Thank you. Yes, which you contributed some wonderful photos to. Oh, amazing photos of the writer's room.
我们太爱听你的故事了。尽管来吧。我特别爱听你们的节目，也喜欢重温那些甚至没有我参与的部分。祝贺你们做出这么棒的播客，还有你们的书。谢谢。谢谢。是的，你还为这本书提供了很多精彩的照片呢。哦，那些编剧室的照片太棒了。
I mean, we can't thank you enough. Yes. Yes. Oh, we love you, Erin. Thank you so much. Likewise. Bye. Muah.
我的意思是，我们对你感激不尽。是的。是的。哦，我们爱你，埃伦。非常感谢。彼此彼此。拜拜。么么哒。
Let's get into this episode. Yeah. It starts in the dark. Mm-hmm. All the lights go out, there's a power failure. Dwight says, guys, come on, follow me to the shelter. How many shelters does Dwight have? I mean, we know he has one at Shroop Farms, but I guess he has one at Dunder Mifflin.
让我们进入这一集吧。好的。开场是在一片黑暗中。嗯-hmm。所有的灯都熄灭了，发生了停电。德怀特说：伙计们，快来，跟着我去避难所。德怀特到底有多少个避难所？我的意思是，我们知道他在施鲁特农场有一个，但我猜他在邓德米夫林公司也有一个。
I'm jealous. I know. You want a bunker. He has food for 14 days. And then there's going to have to be a difficult conversation. So Michael takes the blame. He had his space heater and fan both plugged in to the same outlet, but it's all fine. The lights are back on.
我好嫉妒。我知道。你也想要个掩体。他备有够吃14天的食物。然后接下来就得进行一次艰难的谈话了。于是迈克尔主动承担了责任。他把自己的空间取暖器和电风扇都插在了同一个插座上，但没关系。灯又亮了。
But the servers are down. They need to enter the password to get back in. And can we just all take a minute? I kind of need everyone to just take a minute with me, because what does Pam say? Pam says, wait, does anyone remember when it was set up? And Michael says, like, eight years ago. And then Pam says, oh, Lord of the Rings stuff? Pam.
但是服务器崩溃了。他们需要输入密码才能重新登录。我们能不能都花一分钟时间？我需要大家陪我花一分钟时间，因为帕姆说了什么？帕姆说：等等，有人记得这是什么时候设置的吗？迈克尔说：大概八年前吧。然后帕姆说：哦，是《指环王》那会儿吗？帕姆。
Yeah. Is a Lord of the Rings fan. I want it noted. I don't think she's a Lord of the Rings fan. Yes, she is. Let me have this, Jenna. She's not. She just knows.
是的。是个《指环王》迷。我要把这记下来。我不觉得她是什么《指环王》迷。不，她是。詹娜，你就让我这么认为吧。她不是。她只是知道。
Come on. She knows her office family. Why was that? And she's like, oh, I know what it is. Lord of the Rings was eight years ago. It's probably like some, I bet she couldn't name a reference. She doesn't say anything. Lord of the Rings.
拜托。她很了解她的办公室大家庭。为什么会这样？然后她就像是：哦，我知道那是什么。设置《指环王》的时候是八年前。这可能就像某种——我敢打赌她根本说不出具体指代什么。她什么也没说。《指环王》。
I disagree. I disagree. I think Pam is a big Lord of the Rings fan. She isn't. I refuse. I am Pam. I'm telling you, she's not. This is a trait we share in common.
我不同意。我不同意。我认为帕姆是个忠实的《指环王》迷。她才不是。我拒绝承认。我就是帕姆。我跟你说，她真的不是。这是我们俩共有的特质。
Well, they have to sort of toggle back in their minds about who was the IT guy when this was set up. Yeah. And they realized it was Lawsonge. Yeah. That was what they called him. I love it that they've never known the name of a single one of their IT guys. No, no one.
好吧，他们必须在脑海中回想一下，当年设置这个的时候IT人员是谁。对。他们意识到那是劳森格。对。他们就是这么叫他的。我太喜欢他们连一个IT人员的名字都记不住这件事了。不，谁都不记得。
And guess what the password is? It's Big Boobs with a Z. I did like that Meredith and Angela both chimed in things about Pam. I said drama queen, Angela said nosy. Some side sass during the scene. Well, we had a fan question from Ryan S. in Massachusetts who asked, when the power goes out in the office, since you guys work on a soundstage, how did the whole process of making the lights go out work?
你猜密码是什么？是“大波霸”，中间的o是用字母Z代替的。我确实很喜欢梅雷迪思和安吉拉都在一旁对帕姆评头论足。我说她是戏精，安吉拉说她爱管闲事。这一幕里充满了冷嘲热讽。好吧，我们收到了来自马萨诸塞州的瑞安·S的粉丝提问，他问：当办公室停电时，既然你们是在摄影棚里工作，让全场灯光熄灭的整个过程是怎么运作的？
Was it simple or did it take a lot of planning? Ryan, thank you for this question. This is a kind of like nerdy production question I like. For Randy Cordray, our lighting and electric crew, who was headed up by our gaffer Frank Esposito and his Best Boy Jim Holt, had to do a lot of work to make this happen. Because as Randy pointed out, all of the interior lights in the office go out, but the exterior lights that light up our fakie scrim, you know, to the fake outside out the windows, those all stay on.
这很简单，还是需要大量的规划？瑞安，谢谢你的提问。这正是我喜欢的那种偏技术宅的制作问题。兰迪·科德雷、我们的灯光和电力团队（由灯光师弗兰克·埃斯波西托及其大助杰姆·霍尔领导）为此付出了大量的工作。正如兰迪所指出的，办公室里的所有室内灯都熄灭了，但那些用于照亮我们假背景幕（你知道的，窗外伪造的户外景致）的室外灯却全部亮着。
So we couldn't just like throw the master switch. Right. Some had to stay on, some had to go off. But also, all of our stage lights in like various support rooms around the soundstage like craft service and the sound booth and all of that, they're all on this same like lighting board. Right. And they can't lose lights.
所以我们不能直接拉下总电闸。没错。有些必须亮着，有些必须熄灭。不仅如此，我们在摄影棚周围各种辅助房间（比如剧组餐饮区、录音棚等等）里的所有舞台灯，全部都连在同一个调光板上。没错。而且它们不能断电。
Our sound booth can't lose lights. Yeah. So what they did was they ganged, I guess that's a term or combined, all of the circuits that needed to go dark into a single dimmer and then they would give a cue to our first AD to hit that dimmer and then the appropriate lights would go off and the others would stay on. That's how we did it. All right.
我们的录音棚不能断电。对。所以他们做的是，把所有需要变暗的电路——“成组”——我想这是个专业术语，或者说组合起来，接入一个单独的调光器，然后他们会向我们的第一副导演发出指令，去按下那个调光器，接着相应的灯就会熄灭，而其他的则会保持亮着。我们就是这样完成的。好吧。
Well, let's get into this episode. Ryan and Michael arrived to work and their cars have the Woof.com bumper sticker. Yeah. It says Woof.com whenever, period, wherever, period. I counted. Ryan has one sticker. Michael has nine. Hmm.
好了，让我们进入这一集。瑞安和迈克尔来上班了，他们的车上贴着 Woof.com 的汽车贴纸。对。上面写着：无论何时，句号，无论何地，句号。我数过了。瑞安贴了一张。迈克尔贴了九张。嗯。
That logo was created by Henry Sain and you know, you can go over to the NBC store and they sell Woof shirts and a Woof mug. Still? Yeah. Wow. But no bumper stickers. Well, now we're going to have a joint talking head with Michael and Ryan. Ryan is Woof and Michael is Facebook and they go back and forth.
那个标志是由亨利·塞恩设计的，你知道的，你可以去NBC商店买到 Woof 的衬衫和 Woof 马克杯。现在还有？对。哇。但没有汽车贴纸。好吧，现在我们要看迈克尔和瑞安的双人采访了。瑞安代表 Woof，迈克尔代表 Facebook，两人你一言我一语。
This was reminiscent of a commercial that was running at this time. It was like, what was it, Jen? It was like, um, it's Apple and it was the I'm a Mac, I'm a PC. Yes. And they starred Justin Long as Mac and John Hodgman as PC. Look how excited you got. Did you mini dive this? What'd you do?
这让人想起当时正在热播的一则广告。那是怎样的，詹恩？是这样的，它是什么，苹果公司的广告，内容是“我是Mac，我是PC”。是的。由贾斯汀·朗饰演Mac，约翰·霍奇曼饰演PC。看你兴奋成这样。你做过微型调查吗？你干了什么？
Well, I did a commercial. What? For them. I did an I'm a Mac. I'm a PC commercial. It never aired. Oh. Were you Mac or PC?
嗯，我拍过一则广告。什么？为他们拍的。我拍过“我是Mac，我是PC”的广告。但它从未播出。哦。你是Mac还是PC？
I was neither. Those guys were always Mac and PC. Oh, I see. But this campaign was so successful. People loved it that they started having celebrity guests come in and do other bits with the Mac or with the PC. Okay. So did you do a bit with the Mac or the PC?
我两者都不是。那些家伙永远都是Mac和PC。哦，我明白了。但这个宣传活动太成功了。人们太喜欢它了，以至于他们开始邀请名人嘉宾来和Mac或PC一起拍其他短片。好吧。所以你和Mac或PC搭过戏吗？
It was with both of them. I can't remember a lot of details about it. It's a little fuzzy because it was a really long time ago. It was while we were shooting the office. It was kind of during this time. But they told us ahead of time, we make like 12 of these, but we only pick a few that will actually air. They put them through focus groups.
我是和他们俩一起拍的。我不记得很多细节了。记忆有点模糊，因为那是很久以前的事了。那是我们在拍《办公室》的时候。大概就是在这个时期。但他们提前告诉我们，我们拍了大概12个这样的短片，但我们只会挑选几个真正播出。他们会把这些短片拿到焦点小组去测试。
So you only got paid the big bucks if your commercial got picked. Oh. So my commercial didn't get picked. That focus group was like, they were like, not loving mine, I guess, I don't know. But what I did get was a boatload of Apple credit that never expired. Get out. So for 10 years, every time I needed a new laptop or anything that related anything, I would just go to my contact and be like, Hey, remember, I did that commercial that never
所以只有你的广告被选中了，你才能拿到大笔酬劳。哦。所以我的广告没被选中。那个焦点小组当时大概是——他们好像不太喜欢我的，我不知道。但我得到的是一大笔永不过期的苹果商城额度。少来。所以在长达十年的时间里，每次我需要一台新笔记本电脑或任何相关的东西时，我就会去找我的联系人说：嘿，还记得吗，我拍过那个从未播出的广告。
aired. You said. I'm ready for this item. That's a pretty great sorry you didn't get it gift. It is. No, I mean, I got my sister a laptop. You know, yeah. I got my family, not just for me.
你说的。我已经准备好要这个商品了。这算是一个相当不错的“很遗憾没能播出”的补偿礼物了。确实。不，我的意思是，我给我妹妹买了一台笔记本电脑。你知道的，是的。我给我的家人也买了，不仅是我自己用。
You're like Oprah. You get a laptop. You get a laptop. You get a laptop. I was. It was like the best failed commercial ever. But I have an audio clip from one of their commercials. If you want to play it, I'm not going to be in it, obviously, as we've established.
你简直像奥普拉。你有一台笔记本电脑。你有一台笔记本电脑。你有一台笔记本电脑。我确实是。这简直是有史以来最棒的失败广告了。不过我有一段他们其中一则广告的音频片段。如果你想放的话，显而易见，正如我们已经确定的那样，我不会出现在里面。
But here you go. Hello, I'm a Mac. And I'm a PC. That's it. That's it. That's it. It's been tight. You okay?
但给你。你好，我是Mac。而我是PC。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。最近挺紧张的。你还好吗？
No. I'm not okay. I have that virus that's going around. Oh, yeah. Thank you. You better. You better stay back. This one's a doozy.
不好。我中了现在正流行的那种病毒。哦，天呐。谢谢。你最好。你最好离远点。这次这个病毒可厉害了。
That's okay. I'll be fine. No, no. Do not be a hero last year. There are 114,000 known viruses for PCs. PCs. Not Macs. So describe this.
没关系。我会没事的。不，不。别当什么孤胆英雄。现在有114,000种已知的针对PC的病毒。PC。而不是Mac。所以描述一下这个。
I think I got a crash. Hey, if you feel like that'll help. Good. That was it. That was the bit. It was basically that Mac was always doing well and thriving and the PC was always getting a virus or confused or overwhelmed. So these commercials just threw shade at PCs.
我想我死机了。嘿，如果你觉得这样能好受点的话。好。就是这样。这就是那个短片。基本上就是Mac总是表现良好、欣欣向荣，而PC总是中毒、困惑或者崩溃。所以这些广告就是在贬低PC。
100%. Well, I really wish we could see yours, but I know you can't. I'm sorry. Did you notice during this talking head that Michael wore glasses? Yes. That's because John Hodgman wears glasses. Oh. And so he's doing a spin on the PC guy.
100%。好吧，我真的很想看看你的广告，但我知道你不能播。抱歉。你在这次采访中注意到迈克尔戴眼镜了吗？是的。那是因为约翰·霍奇曼戴眼镜。哦。所以他在模仿PC男。
Now I get it. Well, I know this is how the episode starts that aired, but in the shooting draft, there was a different opening to this episode. Oh. Yeah. It starts with Ryan pitching the whole idea of this company to Michael in his office. Okay. I actually like the version that they aired because they just start in the middle.
我明白了。好吧，我知道播出的剧集是以这个开场开始的，但在拍摄剧本中，这一集其实有一个不同的开头。哦。是的。开场是瑞安在自己的办公室里向迈克尔推销整个公司的概念。好吧。我其实更喜欢最终播出的版本，因为他们直接从中间切入。
You know? Like Michael's in. Yeah. He's enthusiastic. He doesn't have to be convinced. Right. And this is kind of like what Aaron was talking about when we spoke with him, how they would write so much that you could lose part of it, but the full story still is there.
你知道吗？就像迈克尔已经加入了。是的。他很热情。不需要别人说服他。对。这有点像埃伦之前跟我们说的，他们会写很多内容，即使删掉一部分，完整的故事依然成立。
In this alternate opening, Angela is in Michael's office and they're talking about receipts for his taxes and she's holding a box and they kind of argue. And then Angela takes the box and exits in a gruff. And that's when Ryan enters. Okay. But lady, in one of the takes, I hit one of Michael's toys with the receipt box. Okay. And it made it into the bloopers.
在这个备选开场中，安吉拉在迈克尔的办公室里，他们正谈论他的报税收据，她手里拿着一个箱子，两人争论了一番。然后安吉拉气冲冲地拿着箱子走了出去。就在这时，瑞安走了进来。好吧，女士们，在其中一条拍摄中，我用收据箱撞到了迈克尔的一个玩具。好吧。而这被剪进了花絮里。
Lady guesses what I hit. What toy? The clacky teeth? I hit the clacky balls. The clacky balls? Yes. And they would not stop clacking for the rest of the scene. Here.
女士们猜猜我撞到了什么？什么玩具？咔哒咔哒响的牙齿？我撞到了咔哒球。咔哒球？是的。而且在接下来的整场戏里，它们一直咔哒咔哒响个不停。来吧。
Let's listen. Absolutely. Get these done. Out. Out. Hello. Hey. Here to talk about woof.
我们听听。绝对的。把这些搞定。出去。出去。你好。嘿。来聊聊 woof。
Is that cool? Yes. Definitely. As long as you're here to tell me I'm a billionaire. On your way, man. On your way. Sorry. If they try to keep going and BJ tried to make them stop and then he moved his hands
行吗？可以。当然行。只要你是来告诉我我成了亿万富翁就行。走吧，老兄。走吧。抱歉。如果他们试图继续下去，BJ试图让他们停下来，然后他挥了挥手
and they started again. Oh, the old clacky balls. The old clacky balls. I'm telling you. I'm telling you. I am again inspired. We need to do a bonus episode where we break down the whole history of the clacky balls. The clacky ball origin story?
然后他们又开始了。哦，那些老式撞击球。那些老式撞击球。我跟你说。我跟你说。我又受到启发了。我们需要做一个特别节目，好好剖析一下撞击球的整个历史。撞击球的起源故事？
Yes. Ladies who Google. Get ready for it. It's going to be a. I feel called to know more. It's going to be a ball fest. Ball fest. It writes itself.
是的。谷歌女士们。准备好。这将是一个……我觉得我有责任了解更多。这将是一个球的盛宴。球的盛宴。这简直不言而喻。
Erin is about to have one of my favorite lines, which is she doesn't like to be a lousy snitch. A lousy snitch, not just a snitch, but a lousy one. Ryan's making a lot of color copies. It's going to tick her off for the whole episode. Yes, Pam, as office administrator, should care about this and should probably do something about it. She says, let it go. See, now this is when people started to turn on Pam's new job.
艾琳即将说出我最喜欢的台词之一，那就是她不喜欢当一个讨厌的告密者。一个讨厌的告密者，不仅是告密者，而且是个讨厌的告密者。瑞安在复印大量彩色文件。这会让她整集都很恼火。是的，帕姆作为办公室管理员，应该关心这件事，并且可能应该为此做点什么。她说，算了吧。你看，现在这就是人们开始反感帕姆新工作的时候。
They were like, fine, you lied to get it. But now, hmm, well, she invested in Wolf. She really believes in it. She wants a bedroom set. Well, in Michael's office, Michael is talking to Ryan about an investor ski trip. Yeah, and Ryan says, someone's already offered to buy the company, but you know what? He wants to go bigger. He wants more money, so he's going to need more investors.
他们会想，好吧，你是靠撒谎才得到这份工作的。但现在，嗯……好吧，她投资了Wolf。她真的很相信它。她想要一套卧室家具。好吧，在迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔正在和瑞安谈论投资者滑雪之旅。是的，瑞安说，已经有人提出要买下这家公司了，但你知道吗？他想玩得更大。他想要更多的钱，所以他需要更多的投资者。
And he said, that's why he came in today. Michael says, don't you work here? And then Ryan just laughs. Yeah. Well, there was a Ryan deleted talking head where he's super cocky about all of this, and he breaks the fourth wall. Let's hear it. Last I spoke to you about Wolf.com, it was just a prototype.
他说，这就是他今天来的原因。迈克尔说，你难道不是在这工作吗？然后瑞安只是笑了笑。是的。嗯，有一个瑞安被删掉的访谈镜头，他在里面对这一切超级自大，而且他还打破了第四堵墙。我们来听听看。上次我和你聊起Wolf.com的时候，它还只是个原型。
Well, we launched the beta three months ago, and the response has been unbelievable. It's going to be huge. Looks like your little documentary finally found its star. Wolf! Oh, yeah. Yeah. Star of the documentary. Hmm.
嗯，我们在三个月前推出了测试版，反响好得难以置信。这将会是个大热门。看来你们这个小纪录片终于找到主角了。Wolf！哦，耶。没错。纪录片的主角。嗯。
Next up, we are going to learn a little bit about Dwight's childhood. He used to have a place called the Hay Place, and he's going to recreate it for everyone here at Dundermiflin. He's overseeing a bunch of Bales of Hay being unloaded in the parking lot. And Hay Place is going to have games and a maze, all kinds of stuff. Yeah. We had a fan question from HarmGenV in the Netherlands. HarmGen, you are so wonderful.
接下来，我们要稍微了解一下德怀特的童年。他以前有个地方叫“稻草乐园”，他要在邓德米夫林这里为所有人重现它。他正在监督停车场里卸下一堆堆的干草捆。“稻草乐园”里会有游戏、迷宫，各种各样的东西。是的。我们收到了来自荷兰的HarmGenV的粉丝提问。HarmGen，你太棒了。
You send us questions every week. I know. And they're always very good. HarmGen would like to know, how many Bales of Hay did you guys have to get for this episode? Well, Randy was not exactly sure, but we rented them. That was an interesting tidbit. We returned these when we were done. Well, I'm glad.
你每周都给我们发问题。我知道。而且它们总是非常好。HarmGen想知道，为了这一集，你们究竟得弄来多少草捆？嗯，兰迪其实也不太确定，但我们是租来的。那是一个有趣的八卦。我们用完之后把这些都退了。好吧，我很高兴。
I mean, what would we do with them? I don't know. But we got them from a farm in Palmdale, California. We had to pay a truck and a driver to deliver them. They came stacked in like 10 foot high stacks on this big trailer bed. And Randy's rough estimate is that we used around 360 Bales. And that it was our set dressing crew headed up by Steve Rothstein and lead man Jim McDermott are the ones who unloaded all of those Bales and then reloaded them onto the truck after
我是说，不然我们拿它们怎么办？我不知道。但我们是从加利福尼亚州帕姆代尔的一个农场弄来的。我们不得不付钱请一辆卡车和一个司机来送货。它们被堆在那个大拖车斗上，像10英尺高的高塔一样。兰迪粗略估计我们大约用了360个草捆。而且我们的布景团队由史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦（Steve Rothstein）和领班吉姆·麦克德莫特（Jim McDermott）带头，是他们卸下了所有这些草捆，然后在拍摄结束后
the shoot. But we had a fan catch. Many a fan catches. We talked about this in our interview with Erin. These were not Hay Bales. They were Straw Bales. Riley P. from Northern Minnesota said, I have been waiting for this episode ever since your podcast started.
又把它们重新装回卡车上。但我们有一个粉丝抓包。有很多粉丝抓包。我们在对艾琳的采访中谈到过这一点。这些根本不是干草捆。它们是麦秸捆。来自明尼苏达州北部的莱利·P说，自从你们的播客开播以来，我一直在等待这一集。
This was sort of painful to watch as a farmer because those Bales are so clearly straw. And Shania R. from Sydney, Montana said, maybe you guys use straw because it's much lighter and easier to work with, but that's not hay. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, thanks to our associate producer Ainsley Bubba Co. here at Ear Wolf. I have a nice little breakdown to help you know if you are looking at hay or straw. Go Ainsley.
作为一个农民，看这一集简直有点痛苦，因为那些草捆很明显是麦秸。来自蒙大拿州悉尼的沙尼亚·R说，也许你们用麦秸是因为它轻得多，更容易处理，但那不是干草。嗯哼。是的。好吧，多亏了我们在Ear Wolf的助理制片人艾恩斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubba Co.），我有了一个很好的小剖析，能帮你分辨你看到的是干草还是麦秸。加油，艾恩斯利。
Here we go. Hay has seeds in it. Straw does not. Hay is usually more green in color. Maybe think alfalfa, which is a type of hay. Straw is dry and yellow. Hay is used as feed. Yes.
我们开始吧。干草里面有种子。麦秸没有。干草通常颜色更绿。也许可以想想苜蓿，它是一种干草。麦秸是干燥且呈黄色的。干草被用作饲料。是的。
Straw is used for bedding. Straw is also what we used in hay place. That is right. I knew it was straw. As Jenna, you know, my family has a farm and I spent many hours on the tractor with my dad while he was baling hay. You baled hay? I baled hay.
麦秸则用于铺窝。麦秸也是我们在稻草乐园里用的东西。没错。我知道那是麦秸。詹娜，你知道的，我家里有个农场，我和我爸在拖拉机上度过了很多小时，当时他在打干草捆。你打过干草捆？我打过干草捆。
Sometimes we did square bales. Sometimes we did big round bales. We had a little thing that picked up the round bales, this fork, because they're super heavy. But even the square ones are heavy, right? Yes. And we didn't have anything to pick those up. So we had to walk behind the flatbed trailer and throw them on.
有时我们打方捆。有时我们打大圆捆。我们有一个小装置来捡起那些圆捆，这个叉子，因为它们超级重。但即使是方捆也很重，对吧？是的。而且我们没有任何东西可以把它们捡起来。所以我们不得不跟在平板拖车后面走，把它们扔上去。
I couldn't do it. They're like a hundred pounds. Well this is definitely why we had to use straw in the episode, because we had to have just our two crew guys piling all that stuff up. And stacking them. But I will tell you, when I watched this episode, I just got so nostalgic for my dad. I was really missing him because if we would have called him and said, Bill Kinsey, can you break down some hay stats for us, he would have had the time of his life.
我可干不了。它们重达一百磅左右。嗯，这绝对是我们在这一集中必须使用麦秸的原因，因为我们只能靠我们仅有的两个工作人员把所有那些东西堆起来。把它们码好。但我必须告诉你，当我看到这一集时，我对爸爸充满了怀念之情。我真的很想念他，因为如果我们打电话给他，说“比尔·金西，你能为我们分析一些干草数据吗”，他一定会度过他生命中最美好的一天。
I would have loved that. I know. Me too. Well, Angela, you are about to arrive to Hay Place. It's open. People are coming. They're buying tickets. I noticed that you're wearing a wool coat.
我会很乐意的。我知道。我也是。好吧，安吉拉，你马上就要到达稻草乐园了。它开园了。人们正在到来。他们正在买票。我注意到你穿着一件羊毛大衣。
It was so hot the two days we filmed this Hay Place. I don't know if you noticed, but the patrons all sort of have rosy cheeks. We were burning up. I looked at the call sheet. It was 93 degrees. This was the last week of September in 2010 when we shot this. We were having a heat wave as we always do in September. Yeah.
我们拍摄稻草乐园的那两天太热了。你们有没有发现，游客们的面颊都红扑扑的。我们快热死了。我看过通告单。当时是93华氏度（约34摄氏度）。我们拍摄这一集是在2010年的9最后一周。我们正经历着热浪，就像我们每年9月一样。是的。
Late September, early October is the hottest time in LA. I know that because it's also around my son's birthday and we can never have an outside full sun birthday party for him. Also, you can't buy your pumpkins too early here. Oh, no, they melt. They melt and then they get real gross. So I saw you, Ange. I saw you in that wool coat.
9月下旬、10月上旬是洛杉矶最热的时候。我知道这一点，因为这也是我儿子生日左右，我们从来不能为他在户外办一个全日照的生日派对。而且，你在这里不能太早买南瓜。哦，不，它们会融化。它们会融化，然后变得非常恶心。所以我就看到你了，安吉。我看到你穿着那件羊毛大衣。
If you thought I was hot, poor Brian, we'll get to that. Walking around that maze. Running in his wool jacket. Well, Angela's, she's hot to trot, guys. She sure is. She'd like a roll in the hay, please. Yeah. But that'll be $5.
如果你觉得我热的话，可怜的布莱恩，我们待会儿会聊到他。在那个迷宫里走来走去。穿着他的羊毛夹克奔跑。好吧，安吉拉，她现在急不可耐了，伙计们。她确实是。她想要在干草堆里打个滚，拜托。是的。但那要收5美元。
That's not what she meant, Dwight. Dwight. There was more to this Dwight and Angela runner. He continues to blow her off and it really sets up nicely the senator. Well, Jim's very excited. He gives a big woohoo when he gets off the phone. He's on a sales streak. But when he goes to talk to Kevin about it, even though Kevin has done, his commission
她不是那个意思，德怀特。德怀特。德怀特和安吉拉这条支线还有更多内容。他继续对她爱搭不理，这实际上为参议员的出场做了很好的铺垫。好吧，吉姆非常兴奋。当他挂断电话时，他发出了巨大的一声“呜呼”。他的销售业绩一直在连创新高。但当他去找凯文谈论这件事时，尽管凯文已经完成了任务，他的佣金
is zero. Angela's going to say to Jim, you've met your commission cap. You don't get any more commission for the rest of the month. I'm going to say something now that is going to come across to most listeners than most every viewer of the office as a sort of like, welcome to the party, Jenna remark. What? But I just noticed, I just noticed in this scene with Kevin, how Angela has taken up all the space on the top of the partition.
却是零。安吉拉对吉姆说，你的佣金已经达到上限了。这个月剩下的时间你再也拿不到任何佣金了。我现在要说的话，在大多数听众和办公室的绝大多数观众听来，会像是一种“欢迎来到这个派对”式的詹娜言论。什么？但我刚才注意到，我刚刚在这个和凯文的场景中注意到，安吉拉是如何占满了隔板顶部的所有空间的。
Yeah. Every item is hers. Yeah. There's nothing of Kevin's up there. It's like the more thing she puts up there the less she has to see Kevin or something. Exactly. I noted two ceramic cats and two ceramic pelicans and then two stuffed cats. Yes.
是的。每一样东西都是她的。是的。上面没有一件东西是凯文的。这就好像她放上去的东西越多，她就越不用看到凯文之类的。完全正确。我注意到了两只陶瓷猫、两只陶瓷鹈鹕，还有两只毛绒猫。是的。
And I know you talked about the one pelican before, but I didn't realize there were two. But I also noticed something else, which is, why are we storing saber paper shredders on the file cabinets behind Kevin's desk? Why is that where we're keeping them? Don't we have a whole warehouse? Why do we have four shredders on top of the file cabinets? What's that about? Sounds like a mom detective moment.
我知道你之前谈过那只鹈鹕，但我没意识到有两个。但我还注意到了另一件事，那就是，为什么我们要把赛博（Saber）碎纸机存放在凯文办公桌后面的文件柜上？为什么那是我们存放它们的地方？难道我们没有一整间仓库吗？为什么文件柜顶上有四个碎纸机？这是怎么回事？听起来像个妈妈侦探时刻。
Yeah. I don't know. Sex. Do I have your attention? Money. Now I do. At six minutes, 58 seconds during Michael's yelling, did you notice the hay on Dwight's shoulder and hair?
是的。我不知道。性感。我引起你的注意了吗？金钱。现在我引起了。在迈克尔大喊大叫的6分58秒时，你注意到德怀特的肩膀和头发上有干草吗？
I did and so did Sarah P from Fort Worth, Texas, who said, I love catching Dwight with hay in his hair and all over his suit when Michael and Ryan are in the bullpen looking for more investors. So did I. Well, we are going to learn in this scene who has invested in Wolf. Pam raises her hand, Stanley, Daryl. And I don't know if you noticed Andy kind of reluctantly raises his hand. He kind of sort of barely does.
我注意到了，来自得克萨斯州沃思堡的莎拉·P也注意到了，她说过：“当迈克尔和瑞安在办公区寻找更多投资者时，我喜欢捕捉到德怀特头发上和西装上到处都是干草的样子。”我也是。好吧，我们将在这一场戏中了解到谁投资了Wolf。帕姆举起了手，斯坦利、达里尔。我不知道你们有没有注意到安迪有点不情愿地举起了手。他差不多算是勉强举了一下。
If you clocked that, let me know. There was a whole deleted scene where Michael really just manipulates Andy into participating. He didn't want to and Michael just wears him down. I did notice that from Andy and I wondered what the hesitation was. But I find this group of investors very curious. I feel like these are some of the smartest people in the office. You know what I mean? Who have invested their money in Ryan?
如果你注意到了这一点，请告诉我。这里原本有一整段被删掉的场景，迈克尔在其中简直是在操纵安迪参与。他不想参与，而迈克尔只是把他的心理防线磨垮了。我确实注意到了安迪的这一点，并且我在想他犹豫的原因是什么。但我发现这群投资者非常奇妙。我觉得这些人是办公室里最聪明的一些人。你知道我的意思吗？他们把钱投资给了瑞安？
Well, I think because there is a good idea in there, but it's just poorly executed, which Daryl says later. I want to talk about for a minute, though, this talking head that Stanley has. Everyone has different reasons for investing. Stanley wants a decommissioned lighthouse. He wants to live at the top and nobody will know he lives there. And then there's a button that he can press and it launches the lighthouse into space. He's serious.
嗯，我想是因为里面有一个好点子，但只是执行得很糟糕，达里尔后来也这么说了。不过我想花一分钟聊聊斯坦利的这段访谈。每个人投资都有不同的原因。斯坦利想要一座退役的灯塔。他想住在顶端，没有人会知道他住在那里。然后有一个按钮，他可以按下它，把灯塔发射到太空中。他是认真的。
He wants to live in a lighthouse. That is also a spaceship. What? Other people also share why they did or didn't invest. In the shooting draft, Phyllis had a talking head explaining why she did not invest. It read like this, Phyllis, I invested in Bob Vance and per our prenup, I'm just five months away from vesting. Wow.
他想住在灯塔里。那同时也是一艘飞船。什么？其他人也分享了他们为什么投资或没有投资的原因。在拍摄剧本中，菲利斯有一段访谈解释了她为什么没有投资。内容是这样的：菲利斯，我投资了鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance），根据我们的婚前协议，我再过五个月就达到归属期了。哇。
Okay. And then in deleted scenes, Daryl has a talking head of why he invested. Let's hear that. Why would I invest with Ryan? It's a really good idea. Aggregators are one of the few things that produce revenue online. Also the internet has a history of rewarding annoying white boys. All the ingredients are there.
好的。然后在被删减的片段中，达里尔有一段关于他为什么投资的访谈。我们来听听看。我怎么会跟瑞安一起投资？这真是个好主意。聚合器是网上产生收入的少数几样东西之一。此外，互联网历来都会奖励那些讨人嫌的白人男孩。所有的要素都在那儿了。
Well maybe we should take a break because when we come back, Oscar is going to do the thing he does best. He's going to piss on their parade. Well we are back. Ryan is bragging that Washington University wants to buy Woof, but he's not going to sell. Instead he's going to open a second round of investment to family and friends. And the first person that they're going to try to hit up for money is Oscar.
好吧，也许我们该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，奥斯卡要做他最擅长的事。他要在他们的游行队伍里泼冷水。好吧，我们回来了。瑞安正在吹嘘华盛顿大学想买下Woof，但他不打算卖。相反，他要开启第二轮针对家人和朋友的投资。他们要试图拉拢拿钱的第一个人就是奥斯卡。
Mistake. Yeah. Now, Oscar says something really interesting. He says, have you ever considered making Woof like an emergency notification system? So smart. So smart. What a great use of Woof. Ryan's not interested.
大错特错。是的。现在，奥斯卡说了一件非常有趣的事。他说，你有没有考虑过把Woof做成一个紧急通知系统？太聪明了。太聪明了。Woof这真是一个极好的用途。瑞安不感兴趣。
He's like, no, this is about fun. Oscar is going to press Ryan about where they're at financially. And we find out that they can sustain their business for nine days. Nine days. And then they're bankrupt. Michael is bummed because what about the investor ski trip he bought polls? All the investors are going to meet in the conference room. Ryan presents a colorful investment chart, which Erin gives like side eye about.
他说，不，这是为了好玩。奥斯卡要向瑞安追问他们目前的财务状况。然后我们发现他们的资金只够维持公司运转九天。九天。然后他们就破产了。迈克尔很沮丧，因为他买的滑雪杖投资者旅行怎么办？所有的投资者都要在会议室见面。瑞安展示了一张色彩斑斓的投资图表，艾琳对此投去了侧目。
But was that printed there? That looks like something you send out for. Her printer didn't make that. I know. I agree. She's just still so mad about it. I tried to zoom in on it to see what it said, but I couldn't quite tell. Well guess what?
但那是打印在那里的吗？那看起来像是你叫人专门定制送来的东西。她的打印机可做不出那个。我知道。我同意。她只是依然为此非常生气。我试着放大它看上面写的是什么，但我看不太清。好吧，你猜怎么着？
Randy sent it to us. Oh my gosh. What did it say? Well, it's the profit projections. Okay. And it's so ridiculous. It's clearly all that Ryan is obsessed with. Lady, you got to see this.
兰迪把它发给我们了。哦，天哪。上面写了什么？嗯，这是利润预测。好吧。这太荒谬了。这显然就是瑞安痴迷的一切。女士们，你们得来看看这个。
Look at this chart. Oh my gosh. Okay. So according to this chart, it is November right now. They're going to break even any minute. They're going to become profitable before December. They're going to be millionaires by January and billionaires by February. Yeah.
看看这张图表。哦，天哪。好的。所以根据这张图表，现在是十一月。他们随时都会实现收支平衡。他们将在十二月之前开始盈利。他们将在圣经（一月份）成为百万富翁，并在二月份成为亿万富翁。是的。
They're going to break into his projection based on no actual numbers though. Well, on the other side, if you look at the other side of the chart, it looks like we have investors to the tune of $1,500 and something. So $1,580 is going to turn into $1 billion in a matter of months. Yeah. In a matter of months. Wow. This is quite the chart.
他们将突破他的预测，尽管没有任何实际数字作为支撑。嗯，另一方面，如果你看图表的另一端，看起来我们有大约1500多美元的投资者资金。所以1580美元将在几个月内变成10亿美元。是的。在短短几个月内。哇。这真是一张了不起的图表。
Oh, I'm glad I said something. I really enjoyed that. Well, Randy gave us more fun graphics for this episode. Of course, they were all made by Henry Sane and I'm going to put them in stories. Oh, great. Well, I know that the condom wrappers were made by Henry Sane as well. Henry Sane and Phil Shea were very busy this episode. They really were because Ryan's going to start throwing out merch.
哦，我很高兴我开口了。我真的很喜欢那个。好吧，兰迪为我们这一集提供了更多有趣的图表。当然，它们都是由亨利·赛恩（Henry Sane）制作的，我打算把它们发到快拍里。哦，太好了。好吧，我知道安全套包装也是亨利·赛恩制作的。亨利·赛恩和菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）这一集非常忙碌。他们确实很忙，因为瑞安开始抛售周边商品了。
50,000 condoms. 50,000. It's all about the merchandising. And that is when Kelly is going to enter and be like, what are you guys talking about? Hold on a second. This was my idea. Yeah. We had a fan question from Fiona L. in Melbourne, Australia, who said, what actually happens
5万个安全套。5万个。这全都是关于商品化的。而就在那时，凯利要登场了，并且会说，你们俩在聊什么呢？等一下。这明明是我的主意。是的。我们收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本的Fiona L.的粉丝提问，她说，当电视编剧想出一个像Woof这样的发明时，实际上会发生什么？
when television writers come up with an invention like Woof? Who legally owns it? Who's able to make money off of it? Does the network own it? The show? The writers who have their names on the episode or the exact writer who came up with the idea? Is it trademarked? Copyright protected?
谁在法律上拥有它？谁能从中赚钱？是电视台拥有它吗？还是节目组？是名字出现在这一集里的编剧，还是真正想出这个点子的那个编剧？它有注册商标吗？受版权保护吗？
Woof is a great idea and I'm surprised it doesn't really exist. I thought these were all very good questions from Fiona. Yeah. Here's what I was able to find out. I believe it is owned by the whole network. It is not the property of the writer who came up with it. It is the intellectual property of NBC Universal. That's right.
Woof是个好主意，我很惊讶它居然不存在。我觉得Fiona的这些问题都非常好。是的。以下是我能找到的答案。我相信它是由整个电视台拥有的。它不是想出这个点子的编剧的财产。它是NBC环球公司的知识产权。没错。
That's what I would have guessed. Here's the other thing I learned. Whenever any website is mentioned on a television show, it has to be fictitious. It cannot be a real dot com. So way back on nepotism when this idea first came up, they had to go through the process of purchasing the domain names Woof.com, Woof.net, Woof.org. They did it through GoDaddy and the whole thing cost under $100. Randy said that we were required to register the names for two years.
这就是我所能猜到的。我还学到了另一件事。每当在电视节目中提到任何网站时，它都必须是虚构的。它不能是一个真正的.com网址。所以在很久以前的那集“任人唯亲”（Nepotism）中，当这个点子第一次出现时，他们不得不经历购买域名Woof.com、Woof.net、Woof.org的过程。他们通过GoDaddy购买的，整个过程花费不到100美元。兰迪说，我们被要求将这些名字注册两年。
There used to actually be a Woof website. Yes. Like they had it go live. Yes. I reached out to Joy about who was working at NBC.com at this time and she shared with me some of the digital media they built for this episode. First of all, she thought it was really fun that Ryan set up a beta site first where he just gathered information and that would have been set up after nepotism.
以前其实真的有一个Woof网站。是的。就像他们让它上线了一样。是的。我联系了乔亚（Joya），了解当时在NBC.com工作的人，她与我分享了他们为这一集构建的一些数字媒体。首先，她觉得很有趣的是，瑞安首先建立了一个测试网站，他在那里收集信息，这应该是在“任人唯亲”之后建立的。
Okay. And the idea was that Ryan was collecting as much data as he could on everyone before launching his official website a few months later. Sounds scammy. I don't even know what a beta website is. All sounding scammy to me. There was also a component, you get to build your wolf dog avatar. So here are your choices.
好的。这个想法是，瑞安在几个月后推出他的官方网站之前，尽可能多地收集每个人的数据。听起来像个骗局。我甚至不知道什么是测试网站。听起来全都是骗局。还有一个组件，你可以建立你的小狼（wolf）狗狗化身。所以你的选择如下。
You can be a pit bull, a terrier, or a golden retriever. Your fur color can be black, brown, white, or tan. Your tail length can be long, medium, or short. Your ear style can be floppy or pointy. And the collar type can be leather or nylon. Joya said people actually went to the site and they tried to sign up. No. Yes.
你可以是一只斗牛犬、梗犬或金毛寻回犬。你的皮毛颜色可以是黑色、棕色、白色或黄褐色。你的尾巴长度可以是长、中或短。你的耳朵风格可以是下垂的或尖的。项圈类型可以是皮革的或尼龙的。乔亚说人们真的去了这个网站，并试图注册。不会吧。是的。
Joya said that NBC did not save their data because it was too much for the NBC privacy team to deal with. Oh my gosh. So when people entered their information, they just got a wolf sound. That's it. On the website, it's got several different features. When you click on them, they make a noise, like the shop button, bio button. Oh.
乔亚说，NBC没有保存他们的数据，因为对于NBC隐私团队来说，要处理的数据太多了。哦，天哪。所以当人们输入他们的信息时，他们只听到了一声狼叫。就是这样。在这个网站上，它有几个不同的功能。当你点击它们时，它们会发出声音，比如商店按钮、个人简介按钮。哦。
Are they all different forms of barking? They're all different forms of Ryan thanking you and trying to sound cool. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Rye thanking you. How much time did BJ Novak spend on this very odd little subplot recording his voice? Joya went on to share that Ryan Howard also had a Twitter account that they created along with Kelly Kapoor and Aaron Hannon, and the three of them interacted for years.
它们都是不同形式的狗叫声吗？它们全都是瑞安在对你表示感谢并试图听起来很酷的不同形式。抱歉。抱歉。瑞安谢谢你。BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）在这个非常奇怪的小支线剧情录制他的声音上花了多少时间？乔亚接着分享说，瑞安·霍华德还有一个Twitter账号，是他们和凯利·库珀、艾琳·汉农一起创建的，他们三个人互动了好几年。
On real Twitter? On real Twitter, she gave me their account names. All of these Twitter accounts were written by the office writing staff, and the characters had full-blown conversations between 2009 and 2012. Ryan of course tweeted about wolf.com. This was his tweet. Check out, and it's the check symbol, not the word. Check out the new wolf site, wolf.com.
在真实的Twitter上？在真实的Twitter上，她给了我他们的账号名称。所有这些Twitter账号都是由办公室的编剧团队撰写的，这些角色在2009年至2012年间进行了成熟的对话。瑞安当然在推特上发布了关于wolf.com的内容。这是他的推特。来看看，这是一个打勾符号，而不是单词。来看看新的小狼网站，wolf.com。
Sign up. Hopefully soon, you'll hear a wolf next time I tweet at you. Wolf. I just found the Ryan Howard Twitter page, and yeah, he hasn't posted since September 2012. Yeah. Incidentally, Creed also had an official Twitter account, but he didn't interact with the other people in the office.
注册。希望很快，下次我@你的时候，你能听到一声狼叫。Wolf。我刚刚找到了瑞安·霍华德的Twitter主页，没错，他自2012年9月以来就再也没有发过推文了。是的。顺便说一句，克里德也有一个官方的Twitter账号，但他不与办公室里其他人互动。
It was more like Creed Thoughts, but on Twitter. I did not know any of that. Thank you so much, Joya. I have a lot of fun stuff to share in stories this week, all of that website stuff. Well, we should go back to the hay place because a lot has been going on. For example, the hay ride, which was in the back of a Dunder Mifflin paper truck, has returned, and we got a lot of mail about it. You mean the truck with kids inside with the door shut, and they were all really rosy-faced
它更像是“克里德思想”，只不过搬到了Twitter上。我对此一无所知。非常感谢你，乔亚。我本周有很多有趣的东西要在快拍里分享，所有关于那个网站的东西。好吧，我们应该回到稻草乐园，因为这里发生了很多事。例如，干草车（它其实是一辆邓德米夫林纸业卡车的车厢）又回来了，我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。你是说那个车门关着、里面有小孩的卡车，他们出来时脸都红扑扑的？
when they got out? Yes. We had a fan mail flurry, Anne Peay from Minnesota and many others noted that the little boy who gets out of the back of the hay truck, he goes on to play Dwight's nephew in the farm. Oh. What a good catch. Yeah.
是的。我们收到了大量的粉丝来信，来自明尼苏达州的安·皮（Anne Peay）和许多其他人指出，那个从干草车后面出来的小男孩，后来在《农场》（The Farm）中扮演了德怀特的侄子。哦。真是个好抓包。是的。
Angela has given up waiting in the warehouse at their spot. She confronts Dwight, and he blows her off again. Yeah. So she's bummed out. She's sitting by herself on some, I guess they were straw bales. Yeah. A nice man is going to walk up. Yeah.
安吉拉已经放弃在仓库的那个老地方等待了。她去找德怀特对质，而他再次对她爱搭不理。是的。所以她很沮丧。她独自坐在一堆……我猜那是麦秸捆上。是的。一个好心人走了过来。是的。
And he's going to say, do you mind if we share this bale? And she says, sure, there's no charge to sit on the hay, is there? Yes. And that man is a major guest star in the house. Oh, no. Was he also in house? He was in house. This is Jack Coleman.
然后他说，你介意我们共用这捆草吗？她说，当然，坐干草上是免费的，对吧？是的。而这个人是剧中的重要客串明星。哦，不。他也在《豪斯医生》（House）里演过吗？他也在《豪斯》里演过。这就是杰克·科尔曼（Jack Coleman）。
And lady, I got the most wonderful tweet from a fan of our podcast. The Filthy Ape sent us a link to every crossover between the office and house. Come on. There were 148 cast and crew members. How happy are you right now? Who worked on both the office and house. And Jack Coleman is one of them. I had just watched the show Heroes.
女士们，我收到了我们播客粉丝发来的最美妙的推文。“肮脏的猿猴”（The Filthy Ape）给我们发了一个链接，里面列出了《办公室》和《豪斯医生》之间的每一次联动。快看呐。一共有148位演员和剧组成员。你现在有多开心？他们既在《办公室》工作过，也在《豪斯医生》工作过。杰克·科尔曼就是其中之一。我刚刚看过电视剧《英雄》（Heroes）。
And so when he got cast to play the senator, I was like, oh, no, he's a scary guy on Heroes. He plays a lot of villains. He was also a villain on Castle, but he is very well known for also playing the role of Stephen Carrington in the 1980s primetime soap opera Dynasty. Jack is a delight to hang around. He has so many good stories and he's so nice. Well, according to Wikipedia, he's a sixth generation descendant of Benjamin Franklin. What?
所以当他被选中扮演参议员时，我想，哦，不，他在《英雄》里是个可怕的家伙。他演过很多反派。他也是《灵书妙探》（Castle）中的反派，但他最为人熟知的角色之一，还是20世纪80年代黄金时段肥皂剧《豪门恩怨》（Dynasty）中的史蒂芬·卡灵顿（Stephen Carrington）。杰克是个很好相处的人。他有那么多精彩的故事，而且人非常好。好吧，根据维基百科，他是本杰明·富兰克林的第六代后裔。什么？
Mm-hmm. It's true. It's on Wikipedia. But then another guest star alert, the little boy, who's with the senator, was played by Griffin Gluck. And we got a fan catch from Jessica S. from Spruce Grove, Alberta, Canada, who said, I spotted Griffin Gluck, who went on to find success in many TV series and movies, including Tall Girl with Angela Kinsey.
嗯哼。千真万确。维基百科上写着。但接下来还有另一个客串明星警报，和参议员在一起的小男孩是由格里芬·格拉克（Griffin Gluck）扮演的。我们收到了来自加拿大艾伯塔省云杉林镇的杰西卡·S的粉丝抓包，她说：“我发现了格里芬·格拉克，他后来在许多电视剧和电影中取得了成功，包括与安吉拉·金西合作的《高个女生》（Tall Girl）。”
Yes. So listen to this, Tall Girl is so much fun. You know, it's a movie I did for Netflix. But I played Dorky Mom. Steve Zahn and I are like the dorky parents. Our daughter's very tall. But there's this sweet boy that has a crush on her in the movie played by Griffin Gluck. The character's name is Jack Dunkelman.
是的。所以听着，\\u003c高个女生\\u003e太好玩了。你知道，这是我为网飞（Netflix）拍的一部电影。但我扮演的是怪咖妈妈。史蒂夫·赞恩（Steve Zahn）和我扮演怪咖父母。我们的女儿非常高。但电影里有个可爱的男孩暗恋她，由格里芬·格拉克扮演。这个角色的名字叫杰克·邓克尔曼（Jack Dunkelman）。
Griffin is so good in this movie. And in the first movie, we didn't really have any scenes together, but we crossed paths just once and we were hanging out and talking and he said, we've actually met before. And I was like, when, and he said, well, it's just a brief moment. You probably don't remember, but I was the senator's son in Hay Place. And I was like, oh my God, I totally remember they gave him this huge candied apple that he had to try to eat. Uh-huh.
格里芬在这部电影里演得太好了。在第一部电影中，我们其实没有什么对手戏，但我们曾擦肩而过一次，当时我们在一起闲逛聊天，他说，我们其实以前见过。我说，什么时候，他说，嗯，那只是个短暂的瞬间。你可能不记得了，但我就是《稻草乐园》里参议员的儿子。我说，天哪，我完全记得，他们当时给了他一个巨大的糖苹果，他不得不努力去啃。嗯哼。
It was like massive. And I was like, I cannot believe Griffin that you were in Hay Place. But his performance is so good in Tall Girl and Tall Girl too, if you guys haven't seen it. Well, I'm sure he must have looked so different. I mean, he had grown. Yes. I mean, yes.
那简直巨大无比。我说，格里芬，我真不敢相信你演过《稻草乐园》。但他在《高个女生》和《高个女生2》中的表现都太棒了，如果你们还没看过的话。好吧，他当时肯定看起来很不一样。我的意思是，他长大了。是的。我的意思是，是的。
He had been so like, like, I felt old, you know what I mean? I was like, oh, right. But he's a great actor. Now you said something just now, Angela, where you said he played the senator's son. Yes. Fan mail flurry. Lots of people want to know, hey, what happened to the senator's son? Um, guess what?
他当时那么……就像，我觉得自己老了，你知道我的意思吗？我就想，哦，对。但他是个伟大的演员。安吉拉，你刚才说了一句话，你说他扮演的是参议员的儿子。是的。粉丝来信雪片般飞来。很多人都想知道，嘿，参议员的儿子去哪儿了？嗯，你猜怎么着？
I would say this every year on the show. Because later, there's no son. Never. I think I've solved that mystery. Well, I had my own character idea that I would talk to the writers about, because it was a joke between me and the writers. At one point we had a new writer that came on at the end of the series. And I'm going blank on who all was in this conversation.
我在节目里每年都会这么说。因为后来，根本没有儿子了。从来没有。我想我解开了这个谜团。好吧，我曾经有我自己的角色想法，我会和编剧们聊起它，因为这是我和编剧之间的一个笑话。有一次，剧集快结束时，我们来了一位新编剧。我记不清当时有哪些人参与了这场对话。
But I remember them saying something about Angela and the senator having a baby. And I was like, well, you know, he's already a dad. And one of the new writers was like, what? And I'm like, yes, he had a son. Evan T. from Bremerton, Washington thinks he didn't have a son. Ah, Evan, this is very different than my backstory that I created. Evan says, if you watch the scene, the senator never says the boy is his son. It could be his nephew.
但我记得他们提到过安吉拉和参议员生了个孩子。我说，嗯，你知道的，他已经是个爸爸了。其中一位新编剧说，什么？我说，是的，他有个儿子。来自华盛顿州布雷默顿的埃文·T（Evan T.）认为他没有儿子。啊，埃文，这和我创造的背景故事非常不同。埃文说，如果你看那个场景，参议员从来没有说过那个男孩是他的儿子。那可能是他的侄子。
It could be child of a friend. Let's take a listen. Do you mind if we share this bail? Sure. There's no charge to sit on the hay, is there? Probably. Wouldn't you think the $10 to build your own room would include the hay and not just the instructions?
那可能是朋友的孩子。我们来听听看。你介意我们共用这捆草吗？当然。坐干草上是免费的，对吧？大概吧。难道你不觉得建造你自己的房间要花10美元，这应该包含干草而不仅仅是说明书吗？
I mean, I'm starting to think this guy is just trying to make money off the holiday. Yeah, instead of hay place, it should be pay place. Don't laugh at me. No, no, no, I wasn't, no. Just laughing at your joke. No. Pay place. Yeah.
我的意思是，我开始觉得这家伙只是想借这个节日赚钱。是的，与其叫稻草乐园（Hay Place），不如叫收费乐园（Pay Place）。别笑话我。不，不，不，我没有，没有。只是在笑你的笑话。不。收费乐园。是的。
So we can celebrate Thanksgiving Me Your Money Day. That's humorous. Thank you. That's it. Mm. It doesn't say, can my son and I have a seat? Right. No, you're right, Evan.
这样我们就可以庆祝“感恩节，把你的钱交出来日”了。这挺幽默的。谢谢。就是这样。嗯。上面没说，我和我儿子能坐这儿吗？对。不，你说得对，埃文。
My theory that I used to say was, as soon as the senator and Angela got married, she sent him away. Like to military school or something? Yeah, like some kind of boarding school. Well, if it was his son, I believe that's exactly what happened. But I was intrigued by Evan's theory. Evan will have to keep clocking that as the episodes progress with the senator. We've all just made an assumption.
我以前常说的一种理论是，参议员和安吉拉一结婚，她就把他打发走了。比如送去军事学校什么的？对，就像某种寄宿学校一样。嗯，如果那是他的儿子，我相信事情确实就是这样的。但我对埃文的理论很感兴趣。随着剧集围绕参议员不断推进，埃文得继续留意这一点。我们大家都只是做了一个假设。
We should also point out before we leave hay place that Kevin has just entered the maze. Yeah. It's not going to go well. It's not. We have some malaise in the break room. Malaise in the break room? I love it. Yeah.
在我们离开稻草乐园之前，我们还应该指出，凯文刚刚走进了迷宫。是的。这下情况不妙了。确实如此。我们在休息室里有一些不安情绪。休息室里的不安情绪？我喜欢。是的。
Michael is sorting the trash, and Pam is going to have to have like a intervention, I guess. She's doing the Pam thing that Pam does with Michael, where she's the voice of reason and sort of holds up a mirror to what's really happening. And that's usually the only time he can see it. And he's going to say, you may be right, I may be crazy, about Ryan, yeah. Which means Pam knows he wants to break into song. Randy said that we had to pay $25,000. Just for that little moment?
迈克尔正在分类垃圾，而帕姆不得不进行一次干预，我猜。她正在做帕姆对迈克尔时常做的那种事，她扮演理性之声，并有点像照镜子一样指出正在发生的事。而那通常是他唯一能看清的时候。他会说，关于瑞安，你说得也许对，我可能疯了，对吧。这意味着帕姆知道他想引吭高歌了。兰迪说我们必须支付25000美元。仅仅为了那个小小的片断？
For Steve to sing that one line of the Billy Joel song. Whoa. Yeah. What if we sang the whole song? I don't know. Is it like per line? That's a good question. I'll get to the bottom of that.
为了让史蒂夫唱比利·乔尔（Billy Joel）的那首歌的一句歌词。哇。是的。如果我们把整首歌都唱了会怎样？我不知道。它是按行收费的吗？这倒是个好问题。我会查个水落石出。
After this talk with Pam, Michael's going to go find Ryan in his closet office. This scene broke my heart before we discuss it at 15 minutes 30 seconds when Michael opens the door. Did you see what was on Ryan's screen? Some sort of game. Like a baseball game. And he quickly changes it to woof.com. But it was like a video game.
和帕姆谈过之后，迈克尔要去找他壁橱办公室里的瑞安。在我们讨论它之前，这个场景伤透了我的心：在15分30秒时，当迈克尔打开门。你看到瑞安的屏幕上是什么了吗？某种游戏。就像棒球游戏。而他迅速把它切换成了woof.com。但那像是个电子游戏。
Yeah. But he quickly changes it to look like he's busy. Exactly. Yeah. It's really sad because it's very clear that Ryan does not have Michael's best interests at heart. No. And he wants Michael to take out a second mortgage on his condo.
是的。但他迅速切换过去，看起来像是在忙正事。完全正确。是的。这真的很悲伤，因为很明显，瑞安并没有把迈克尔的最大利益放在心上。没有。而且他想让迈克尔拿他的公寓去办二次抵押贷款。
And Ryan says, we're going to do so much together. We're going to have trips and dinners and Michael's like, well, we've never even had a dinner. How about tonight? And Ryan's like, yeah, I'm busy. Yeah. Well, Darryl is going to be less subtle. Darryl is going to literally remove, yeah.
瑞安说，我们要一起做很多事情。我们要去旅行、吃晚餐，而迈克尔却说，嗯，我们甚至从来没有一起吃过晚餐。今晚怎么样？而瑞安却说，嗯，我很忙。好吧，达里尔就不会这么委婉了。达里尔会直接把……是的，揪着他的衬衫。
By his shirt. And everyone is going to really put the pressure on there in the kitchen and they're all sitting saying they want to sell, except Michael still doesn't want to sell. He still gets Ryan's back. By the way, something we forgot to mention was why Washington University wants to buy woof. Oh, well, this is pretty important. They realize it's just for the domain name.
每个人都会在厨房里真正施加压力，他们都坐着说他们想卖掉，除了迈克尔依然不想卖。他仍然在维护瑞安。顺便说一句，我们忘记提及的一件事是华盛顿大学为什么要买下woof。哦，嗯，这相当重要。他们意识到这只是为了域名。
It's the Washington University Public Health Fund. Yeah. And that should really show you how much this business is suffering. That just someone wanting to buy the domain name back. Right. That is enough to get out. Well, while this is going on, Jim has decided to spend the rest of his day manipulating the audiobook of Joe Bennett's book.
那是华盛顿大学公共卫生基金会。是的。这真的应该让你看看这家生意正遭受多大打击。仅仅是有人想把域名买回去。这就足够让人退出了。嗯，正当这一切发生时，吉姆决定把剩下的一天时间花在恶搞乔·贝内特（Joe Bennett）的有声书上。
Yes. Yes. Basically pranking Gabe. Yeah. So he manipulates this message that sounds like Joe telling Gabe that she's going to read her audiobook to him and he has to follow along to make sure she doesn't make any mistakes. Do you know what I thought Jim was going to do?
是的。是的。基本上就是在整蛊加布（Gabe）。是的。所以他篡改了这条信息，听起来像是乔在告诉加布，她要亲自读她的有声书给他听，而他必须跟着听，以确保她没有犯任何错误。你知道我以为吉姆要做什么吗？
What? I thought he was going to edit the audiobook to say, let Jim have his commissions back. Oh, that would have been good. We did have a fan catch from Louisa L in Massachusetts who said, wouldn't Jim's extension number have come up and not Joe's when like, quote unquote, Joe calls Gabe? So busted. I know Gabe was not paying attention. Dwight is now going to crown himself the Haking.
什么？我以为他会编辑有声书，让它说：让吉姆拿回他的佣金。哦，那倒是个好主意。我们确实收到了来自马萨诸塞州路易莎·L的粉丝抓包，她说：“当所谓的乔给加布打电话时，难道不应该显示吉姆的分机号而不是乔的号码吗？”当场抓获。我知道加布根本没在听。现在德怀特要给自己加冕为干草之王（Haking）。
Yes. It's something he's always wanted. For years he was looked over. I guess most kept getting it. He's super happy about it. And there was a deleted scene between Angela and Dwight that I think was the nail in the coffin for her to really warm up to the senator. Oh, let's hear it.
是的。这是他一直想要的东西。多年来他一直被忽视。我猜大多数时候都是别人得到它。他对此超级高兴。安吉拉和德怀特之间有一个被删掉的场景，我认为那是让她真正对参议员产生好感的最后一根稻草。哦，我们来听听看。
Dwight, it's time. Sorry, women aren't allowed to address the Haking directly. Go away. It's okay. I've been waiting for you all day. What are you talking about? Right. The thing.
德怀特，时间到了。抱歉，女人不准直接和干草之王说话。走开。没关系。我等了你一整天。你在说什么？对。那件事。
Okay. Just get yourself ready and cleaned up and I'll meet you there when this winds down. Be gone, woman. Yeah, be gone, woman. And while he says that, he's gnawing on a giant like turkey leg and wearing a fake crown made of straw. Well, I believe that was meant to be a goat leg because, remember, the petting zoo? Oh, it was roasting goats.
好吧，自己准备好，收拾干净，等这边的活动散了我在那儿见你。滚开，女人。是的，滚开，女人。当他说这话时，他正在啃一只巨大的火鸡腿似的肉，头上戴着一顶用麦秸做的假王冠。嗯，我相信那本该是一只山羊腿，因为，还记得吗？那个动物园？哦，那是烤山羊。
Yeah. It was closed right before the goat roast. Yeah. Alicia Raycraft, our costume designer, made the whole Haking outfit. It's really great. She sent me some of the sketches when she was sketching it out. It's pretty perfect. Clearly though, Dwight was always meant to win because that crown was never going on
是的。就在山羊烤好前不久关门了。是的。艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特（Alicia Raycraft），我们的服装设计师，制作了整套干草之王服装。真的太棒了。当她勾勒草图时，她给我发了一些草图。简直完美。不过很明显，德怀特注定要赢，因为那顶王冠根本不适合戴在小孩子的头上。
a child's head. No. I mean. It was a huge head in real life. And it fit him perfectly. Kevin is still stuck in the maze. Poor Brian. Poor Brian this day, running around 90 degrees, full sun.
不。我的意思是。在现实生活中那是颗很大的脑袋。而且它非常适合他。凯文仍然被困在迷宫里。可怜的布莱恩。可怜的布莱恩这一天，在90度高温、全日照下跑来跑去。
What we do for our craft. I know. Well, you know, in the kitchen, Michael was not going to sell. He said he believed in Ryan, that he would give Ryan the full nine days to turn woof around and then they would sell. It's kind of cool. He says, you know, the world sends people your way. Sometimes you don't know why, but he always sticks with his people, basically, I'm summing
为了我们的手艺，我们真是拼了。我知道。嗯，你知道的，在厨房里，迈克尔不打算卖。他说他相信瑞安，他会给瑞安足足九天时间让woof扭亏为盈，然后他们再卖。这挺酷的。他说，你知道的，世界会把人们带到你身边。有时你不知道为什么，但他总是坚持和自己人在一起，基本上，我是在总结。
up. And I actually thought it was, it was very Michael. And he goes through and he kind of likens everybody to a playing card. He's the Joker. Yes. And it's true that Ryan is a two, but sometimes twos can be wild. Yeah. Mm hmm.
而我其实觉得这很……非常迈克尔。他一路走来，把每个人比作一张扑克牌。他是小丑。是的。而且确实瑞安是一张2，但有时2可以是百搭牌。是的。嗯哼。
He really doesn't give up on people. But Ryan's going to give up on woof. Thank God. He spent about two hours in his closet and the episode ends with Michael getting a final woof. Yes. It said, woof from Ryan Howard, decided to sell company. Thanks bro.
他真的不会放弃任何人。但瑞安要放弃woof了。谢天谢地。他在他的壁橱里呆了大约两个小时，这一集的结尾是迈克尔收到了最后一个来自woof的信息。是的。上面写着：“来自瑞安·霍华德的woof，决定出售公司。谢啦兄弟。真是段难忘的旅程。”所以就像是一起度过了几天。
Hell of a ride. So it's like a few days together. And one last thing we have to address is that the Hay King goes looking for Angela. Mm hmm. And taped to the warehouse door where they hook up is a voided contract and the punch card. And as Angela is leaving, the senator asks, if I were to call Dunder Mifflin and ask for Angela Martin, would I get through to you?
我们必须解决的最后一件事是，干草之王去找安吉拉了。嗯哼。贴在他们亲热的仓库门上的，是一份作废的合同和打卡机。当安吉拉离开时，参议员问：“如果我给邓德米夫林打电话找安吉拉·马丁，能转接到你那里吗？”
And she says, yes. And if I were to call your home and ask for your wife, would I get her? And he says, no, my wife died. He's the widower. Mm hmm. It's a tiny smile from Angela on that one. And that, my friends, was woof.com. Thank you so much for sending in your questions.
她说：“可以。”“那如果我给你的家里打电话找你的妻子，能找到她吗？”他说：“不，我妻子去世了。”他是个鳏夫。嗯哼。安吉拉对此露出了一个微笑。而那，我的朋友们，就是woof.com。非常感谢你们发来提问。
Thank you so much to Aaron Scherr for stopping by and letting us chat his ear off. Thank you to Randy Cordray for all your behind the scenes info. And Ainsley, thanks for that breakdown on Hay versus Straw. All right, you guys have a great one from Two Office Ladies. We wish you the best. See you soon. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
非常感谢艾伦·舍尔（Aaron Scherr）光临并让我们听他唠叨个不停。感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）提供所有的幕后信息。还有艾恩斯利，谢谢你为我们剖析干草与麦秸的区别。好了，各位办公室女士祝你们过得愉快。我们祝你们一切都好。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitropremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitropremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·菲舍尔（Cody Fisher）担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。如需收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问stitropremium.com。在Stitropremium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。